that's not the plan
I mean it's crazy too because your
output is at such a high level like I
think Gucci's album that he dropped
either earlier this year or late last
year had like 70 songs you just dropped
the 33 song project you know what I'm
saying like because you can't be [__]
with the Gucci future
Lil Wayne
and I'll say Boosie that's like my
mixtape Mount Rushmore that's like
if you really pay attention that's
really what all my [__] is and then when
I heard Thug later on that's what kind
of like helped me play with my voice
more and [__] like really being a big
fan of them yeah Thug did a good job of
I always say using his voice is like an
instrument kinda yeah cause I've been on
that but I just was like kind of like
not going all the way
full flesh like pop star with it because
of where I was from and who I was around
because it sounded like substance yeah
it's like I slipped like the gangster
lyrics in it but the whole setup of that
song is like this [__] really like not
even some of you would think a black
[__] would make you know what I'm
saying and that's why that [__] is so
Timeless and [__] like that yeah you uh
you pride yourself on not necessarily I
saw you correct somebody
in terms of like not making quote
unquote West Coast rapist
you go to a record stop a record store
sometimes you'll see West Coast rap 100
that's a genre I'm saying I'm not the
genre that was like some characters
for that time we all characters so I'm
not saying that to take nothing from
them but those people were from places
that aren't even close to where I'm from
you know what I'm saying they're not
even from the state that I'm from but a
lot of them not even just like at the
end of the day I'm telling the story of
you know going up Wilmington to going
down Rosecrans I'm going from Wise
Compton and Gardena like the regions
that I really know you know I'm painting
that picture you know what I'm saying so
I just
try to show people like you know the
reason I don't jump on that is because
I'm a real trap [__] too right you know
what I'm saying I'm a real out of town
[__] too I'm a real you know what I'm
saying I still be with my peoples from
other states you know what I'm saying
well you described your last day before
turning yourself in as to me a perfect
example of what you were able to help do
and that was Bridge
a whole world of like you mentioned pump
and Uzi right and shout out to Desto dub
who actually helped a lot of this too
but just there's like a whole generation
of kids that were looking for like a an
artist like yourself like Draco like
Shoreline to kind of like not
necessarily you know like you said be
honest it's like it's like six or seven
artists that's out right now I won't I
won't just say their name in case it
makes it I want to make it seem like
it's a flex on right but they'll give me
my you know respect on that [__] of me
like opening up
a door where where artists could be
different or you could be more melodic
but you could talk about what you want
to talk about
or like even like the producer there's a
lot of people that make their own beats
or people that just only make beats uh
Inspire producers just like producing
never been or you know what I'm saying
just like some of my bigger songs sweet
lady you know what I'm saying or people
you know what I'm saying just seeing
like those are real people in the songs
and [__] I just let people say you know
tell your own story I'm saying be
yourself if you like whatever you like
you know what I'm saying